- We are living through a global pandemic
that has absolutely
disrupted life as we know it.
No matter who you are,
this crisis has affected
every aspect of society, of
America, and of the world,
whether that's from sickness, to death,
to economic devastation and
possible massive recession.
So what do we do?
How do we adapt?
And how do we really
survive and also thrive
as entrepreneurs and content creators?
Well in this episode of the
Think Marketing Podcast,
I'm gonna be breaking down five strategies
as well as a couple inspiring
case studies from businesses
that are pivoting during this time
so that you can keep
fighting for your family,
for your future, for your community,
and that you can profit,
not from this pandemic
but during this pandemic.
Let's get into it.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Podcast,
the number one podcast for
growing and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice
and the latest money making strategies,
working right now online.
So whether you wanna grow
your YouTube channel,
or you wanna maximize video
across all of social media,
this podcast is for you.
- Hey welcome back to the
Think Marketing Podcast.
I'm Sean Cannell, and I'm
fired up you're here today,
come on, even in the midst
of really crazy times,
No matter where you are in the world,
I wanna first and foremost say that,
on behalf of myself and
the Think Media team,
our heart goes out to yeah.
We're praying for you and your family
and the world right now,
and we just really believe
that this is a time
that we need to come
together and stay focused
on how we can be productive
and not get under the weight
of this crazy situation.
We've already seen here a real freeze,
as I record this, we're in Las Vegas,
and the city is shut down.
The strip doesn't have lights on.
A lot of people have already been laid off
and lost their jobs.
And the prediction is, that
as many as 400,000 people
could be laid off here in Las Vegas.
Of course, we're at the
convergence of travel,
of flights, of restaurants, of casinos,
of non-essential businesses.
And so I don't know how
this is affecting you
and your business.
Maybe you're doing great;
maybe you've lost your job.
I believe that these five
strategies are gonna be something
that we can put into practice,
to not just get through this,
and look, we will get through this.
This too shall pass.
But also how you can even
thrive during this time.
And so number one is create over consume.
Create over consume.
If you're an entrepreneur listening
to the Think Marketing Podcast,
and this is a more important time
than ever before to be
leaning in to creating.
Right and if you're a content creator,
that's already your job.
That's already your vocation
is creating content.
Even if it's a side hustle, now's the time
to be creating over consuming.
We saw an article that
really speaks to opportunity
for us and what society is doing.
And Neilsen is predicting
that content consumption
right now is over 60%.
It's over double.
The internet is trying to wonder how
to handle the bandwidth.
YouTube has reduced the quality in the UK
in other countries so they can come,
they can fulfill the demand
of people actually consuming
content on the internet.
But here's what this means for you,
most people are consuming.
Most people are scrolling on their phone,
letting the news come to them,
or watching your content,
educational content,
inspirational content,
and I wanna challenge you
to create more than you consume.
Facebook has acknowledged
that heavy social media use,
particularly the kind that
involves passive consumption,
rather than active posting can
actually trigger a low mood.
I don't know if you've ever felt
that after you just scrolled on Instagram,
scrolled on Facebook, just
wandered around the internet,
that you didn't feel better afterwards,
that you actually felt worse.
So to protect ourselves, and our mindset,
and our heart, and our
focus during this time,
I think we need to be
careful what we're consuming,
I think we should scroll less.
But we also need to be thinking about
being intentional about creating.
There's so many things we
can't control right now,
but let's focus on what we can control.
You can control how many videos you post.
You can stick to your daily routine.
Get up, create content, do a live stream,
shoot a video, punch fear in the face
and post that video.
And especially, if you're
finding yourself quarantined
in some way, this is definitely the time
to be creating more than you consume.
So here's a couple questions for yeah.
How much time did you spend
creating this past week,
versus consuming?
Like how much time did you
spend planning out videos,
doing key word research,
thinking about trends?
And look, you don't
need to be talking about
this particular virus or
this particular pandemic.
You may be addressing
just the kind of general
Zeitgeist and the mentality
of the world right now.
Look, people are looking
for at home workouts.
They're looking at how to cook at home.
They're looking at ways
to make money on the side.
They're looking at ways to
learn software, learn tech.
There's so many things.
They're looking for a lot
of entertainment content.
They're looking for a recap
of Altered Carbon, season two.
They're looking for somebody to talk about
the Marvel MCU, the Marvel Universe,
and the movies that they're watching.
There's a lot of opportunity
right now to be creating.
But you gotta get in the
game, you gotta stay focused,
and really be careful
about your consumption.
So are you spending more time creating
this past week than consuming?
And then over the last week,
if you have been consuming,
have you been consuming more drama
or more concept that is helping you grow?
Now what I am not saying is
that you shouldn't be informed.
What I am not saying is that
you shouldn't have the facts.
you shouldn't be vigilant
about knowing the information
and protecting your family
and staying home and paying
attention to whatever
your regulations in your
area is, any of that.
What I am saying though is that there is
a tipping point to it,
where you maybe don't need
to get up first thing
in the morning and just
hear a recap of how bad things are.
Like, there's not a lot you
could change about that,
and you definitely probably don't need
to have over indulgence of
content that's just drama,
that's this one person
saying the same thing
in a different way, and maybe,
it's better to spend our
energy consuming content
that can help us grow.
So if you are consuming
content, which I am a lot,
I'm thinking about what
can I learn right now,
what skills can I double down on.
My Amazon, I'm ordering
Amazon books and Audibles,
and I am consuming but I'm thinking about,
come on, as a content
creator and entrepreneur,
this is the time to be consuming content
that's gonna help you grow.
I hope you stay subscribed here
to the Think Marketing Podcast.
Check out what we're doing on Think Media.
Check out the various content.
I hope you're on our newsletter.
We got a lot of content your
way that's gonna help you
stay focused on what you can control,
which is building your
business, serving people,
being creative in the midst of a crisis.
Well, hey my second tip
here is sharpen your skills.
Sharpen your skills.
The famous quote from Abraham Lincoln,
the American president is this.
Give me six hours to chop down a tree,
and I will spend the first
four sharpening the ax.
Man what a great post there that speaks to
when it comes to creating,
that we do need to spend time
that we're actually, instead
of just shootin' videos,
and being stuck maybe and
like what do I say next?
Or what's the next video I should make?
Or what's the next live
stream I should do?
We need to be sharpening the
ax, sharpening our skills.
What skills can you sharpen right now?
When I think about the
skill set needed for YouTube
and affiliate marketing and
social media and live streaming,
it's sharpening our communication skills.
It's sharpening our understanding
of how to write titles
and create thumbnails.
It's sharpening our
ability to create videos.
ability to understand words
like copywriting, not
copyrighted material,
but like the art of writing
persuasive marketing copy.
There's some great books on that.
And we'll of course, always link resources
in the show notes.
And there's so many different
skills that are necessary
for content creators.
Ask yourself this question.
What's the next skill, or
the most important skill
you could work on right now.
Mastering YouTube, if you haven't watched
our free master class
at ThinkMasterclass.com
It's 90 minutes where it's gonna teach you
how to master YouTube, how YouTube works,
and actually, how you could
be using YouTube right now
in an intelligent way that
can grow your business
and make a difference.
Sharpen your skills.
Look if I got six hours
to do a project, man.
I'm gonna spend four hours making sure
that I have it planned,
I have it outlined.
When I do a live stream,
and when I record,
when I record this podcast, I'm here
and I'm just sitting down
and I'm shooting this,
but I just, I'm not winging it.
I've got my notes over here.
I'm on my Google Docs.
I've got the things outlined.
I've done some research.
I've looked up some articles.
So I spend some time making
sure that the content
was sharp so that I could deliver in a way
that will add value to you.
What is the most important skill right now
that you could sharpen during this time?
That's something you can control.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow this Video Live, a $1500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review,
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
Well hey if you get value out of this,
and you are watching on
YouTube, hit the like button
and if you're watching it on a podcast,
maybe a good time or
listening, I should say,
to maybe share it or rate
and review the podcast
wherever you are listening to it.
But the third tip here is
cultivate creative thinking.
Right now, we need to be more
creative than even before.
And our company is called Think Media,
and one of the things we
wanna challenge you to do
is think different.
And that couldn't be more
important than right now.
You gotta cultivate creative thinking.
I understand that you may
have been punched in the face
by this crisis.
I talked to somebody from
our community recently,
real estate agent.
No one's really buying homes,
selling homes in New York.
His income is completely frozen up,
and he just finds himself now,
at home with time on his hands,
but no income and no money coming in.
And maybe your in that situation.
And my heart goes out to
you and I empathy for that
but I'm also going to
challenge you to say,
look that may be the
circumstance you find yourself
in right now, but you gotta get creative.
You gotta think different.
You gotta think outside of the box.
Some YouTube channels
right now are blowing up.
They're getting more
views than ever before
'cause there's more
people consuming content.
Some industries and
channels are going down.
I've heard that some travel
channels are struggling
'cause people aren't
traveling, so they're like,
I don't really need to research it.
I don't really need to
look into it right now.
Therefore you have to think
different and think creatively.
And here's one of the
things that can happen
is there's a Forbes article
that was titled this,
Fear Shrinks Your Brain and
Makes You less creative.
Right now, society is in
a lot of fear thinking,
a lot of hysteria, panic
buying, all the toilet paper
and all the frozen pizzas in the world
that any person could possibly buy.
And the problem with fear thinking is that
it actually kills our creativity
and as a content creator, and
as an entrepreneur right now,
creativity is one of your
most valuable assets.
So you have to be making sure
that your mindset's not in fear,
that you're standing in faith.
Come on, that you are
fighting to be creative.
And what it actually,
the article broke down
is this concept of neuroplasticity.
Now I'm not a neuroscientist, but this is
my understanding of it is that our brains
actually shrink when we're afraid,
and when we're being creative
and when we're in confidence,
our brain's actually are more fluffy
and they're more healthy, okay.
And the analogy is this.
If you've ever driven on a
main street in your city,
could be on the highway,
it could be on a back road
that a lot of people have
driven on year over year.
Maybe you've noticed
that there's been ruts
that have actually been like
driven in to the concrete.
And it could be scary.
If you're driving down the
highway at 60 miles per hour
and you get into that area of ruts,
it'll almost like cause your car,
your tires are in it, but
if you drive through it,
it sort of like pulls the steering wheel
because over and over and over cars
have been driving on these roads.
Well the concept of neuroplasticity
is that that is how are brains work.
That if we're constantly worrying,
and we're constantly afraid,
and we're constantly in fear,
that it actually creates
neural pathways in our brain
that condition us to think that way.
The extreme of it is PTSD.
That going through trauma,
going through extremely
intense situations that cause
our bodies to be shocked
and make us react, once
somebody maybe comes back
from having served our country in war
and they have PTSD, if
someone comes up behind them,
they're scared by that because of
what's has happened in
their past is causing them
to be influenced in the present.
So what does that mean?
It means we have to be intentional
that we're guarding our creative thinking.
I understand that the fear is real.
I understand that the
panic and the hysteria
is real right now, but we
have to find a way around it
to say look, I'm not gonna be afraid.
I'm gonna tap in to confidence.
I'm gonna get up in the morning,
get my mind right, get my heart right,
whatever your morning
routine is right now,
now's the time not to skip on it.
I get up, come on, I
have to get up and pray.
I spend for me, I spend
some time reading my bible.
I spend some time listening
and reading things
that are gonna inspire me.
And I spend time focusing
on what I can control.
'Cause I realize as an entrepreneur,
I need fresh confidence every single day.
I'm not fearless.
I have fear just like you.
I'm worried about the baby
that we have on the way right now.
My wife's pregnant, second trimester.
I'm worried about our team
and can we make payroll.
I'm worried about what's gonna happen
in our business tomorrow.
I'm worried just like you about
is this gonna keep working,
what's gonna happen.
Fear is normal but we have
to overcome fear with faith.
And think about right now,
how you can stay in faith
and guard your creative thinking.
And here's some case studies that I love
that kind of show this, lots
of business owners are doing.
The first one is this
restaurant called Canlis.
Now Canlis is a fine dining restaurant
in Seattle, Washington.
It's amazing.
In fact, my cousins used to work there.
When we say fine dining,
this is the real deal.
They've got the sommelier.
Sure you could drop a
couple hundred dollars
on a bottle of champagne, or
a few thousand if you want.
They have a lot of the
big businesses in Seattle
or we'll get a private room there
and you may know though
that a lot of restaurants
have been shut down.
They've had to close their dining rooms.
And so, Canlis, their entire
business was disrupted.
The owners, they're income,
the employees that they wanna pay
and take care of.
So they could've just shrunk back in fear
and when you're afraid, again,
fear shrinks your brain.
But you have to rise up and
find something in your soul,
something in your heart to say no.
I'm gonna rise up and be creative.
And so here's what they did.
They launched three businesses
out of their one business
called, the first one was
the Bagel Shed at Canlis.
That was the breakfast business.
So people could come and
get bagels and coffee
and like these bagel sandwiches.
They launched the Canlis drive through,
that in the middle of the
day, you could drive through
and you could get a burger and fries.
And here's what's crazy is
they reinvented themselves.
'Cause it's not fine dining anymore.
It was back in the day,
before all this panic,
it was come in, fine dining, where a suit.
Now it's like $14 burger and fries.
And they launched Canlis
Family Meal, a dinner solution,
where they will deliver a bottle of wine,
and some salad and a
meal to you at dinner.
And if you go on their
Instagram, you could see them
in the war room, planning this out.
They're like we're coaching our employees.
We're coaching our team.
We're launching new graphics,
launching three businesses
out of our current business
to adapt to this crisis.
Canlis is an example of how to thrive
and survive during a crisis.
It hasn't been without problems.
They've been having people
sneak in the drive through
and people get upset.
They've been selling out.
They've been trying to
communicate on social media.
One night, they even went to
they set up at Canlis.com/piano,
and they had the live, fine
dining piano guy playing.
And it would be broadcasted to your house.
So you could play that in your house,
while they bring the family meal
and get that fine dining experience
and kind of some vibes in your house.
It's adapt or die right now, friends.
It's time to adapt and think
about how we could be creative
during this season.
SoulCycle, known for coming down, right
and you would get in a room
and you get on those bikes
and I went to GRIT cycle
once with my friend,
Chalene Johnson and Bret Johnson.
One of the dopest things I've ever done.
I remember, there's like
this chick up there,
she's like a DJ.
She's got her music and all of a sudden
then the lights went black
and there was like lasers
and she'd be like, "All right here we go.
"Here we go."
And then like beats would drop.
And she's like, "Push it.
"Turn your intensity up to 10."
And you're sweatin' in there.
And you're shoulder to shoulder.
Well, that business doesn't work right now
with social distancing.
People were are told to stay at home,
stay in quarantine and so, SoulCycle,
what are they gonna do?
Like, they just gotta
shut down their business,
just capitulate to the crisis and give in?
No, what they did is they've
been renting their bikes out
that were in the room,
so that people could take
those bikes home and then
they've been streaming
the workouts because
SoulCycle is a community thing
and that way people can actually
still do their SoulCycle,
kinda like that other brand, who's name
Pent, Pedalton, Pendelton.
I'm probably missing
it here on the podcast,
but you know the one I'm talking about.
They're adapting.
They're adapting to the
times and thinking about
how they can cultivate creative thinking
during this crisis.
How could you cultivate
creative thinking right now.
How can you punch fear in the face
and rise up and think about,
I'm gonna be creative.
I'm gonna look for a different
way to approach this.
I'm gonna keep listening,
consuming the right kinda content
to find that idea.
I'm not gonna give up reading.
I'm not gonna give up studying.
I'm not gonna give up on that
online course I invested in.
I'm actually gonna consume it, take notes,
and find a creative path out of this.
One other example is Heather Torres,
from the Think Marketing Podcast,
recently got a dog a few
months back named Kobe.
And Kobe's this incredible
puppy and if you could
check her out on Instagram,
Miss Heather Torres,
you could see Kobe.
Well, she's working with a dog trainer,
and that dog trainer's
business has been disrupted.
As people are supposed to be
completely quarantined and
not connecting with others,
but the dog trainer
launched a new business
of going to people's houses
and then taking their dog
on a walk for them.
That person maybe still has their job,
still has to do do something and so,
it was a creative addition to the business
that they already have.
Heather's also working with him
to talk about why now's the time
to be creating Instagram
Stories, and live streams
and YouTube videos and
all the kind of stuff
that we talk about here at
the Think Marketing show,
to be creative in this time of crisis.
Tip number four is self care.
We talked about tip number one,
create over consume, right?
Tip number two, sharpen your
skills during this time.
Tip number three, cultivate
creative thinking.
And tip number four is self-care.
My friend, this is not the time to neglect
your most important habits.
This is the time to
double down on discipline.
But it's also the time to make sure
you're taking care of yourself.
Look, we're all at a heightened
level of stress right now.
We're at a heightened level of pressure.
We're at a heightened level of
worry, no matter who you are.
And so if you're going
to be a content creator
and an entrepreneur that
survives and thrives.
You have take care of yourself
and be even more intentional
about that right now.
So just think about, what is maybe
your most important habits or some habits
you think for yourself that
you need to focus on right now.
Just making sure you get enough sleep.
Not getting enough sleep
is like the equivalent
of being like hammered drunk, they say,
in terms of your cognitive ability
and your decision making ability
if you don't get enough sleep.
You need your best
decision-making right now.
You need your best will power right now.
This means, staying hydrated.
In an upcoming episode, I'm
gonna be sharing with you
my tips from working from home.
I've been working from home full time
for the last five years
and part time for over 10,
and I've had to learn a lot of habits
to stay hydrated and
eat well, and make sure
that I keep my energy
up throughout the day.
But just what does self care mean for you?
You maybe need to be the leader right now.
And I believe we all should try to rise up
and ask ourselves, how
can you be a role model
and how would your highest
self show up right now
for your kids, for your
family, for your spouse,
for your small group, for your church,
for your relatives?
What do they need from you?
I think they need for you to be strong,
and need you to have peace
in the midst of the storm.
They need you to be vigilant and assertive
around being protective and
getting enough toilet paper
and getting enough food.
But they don't need to see you panicking.
And I think they need to
see you being productive.
What that means that
you need to make sure,
it's impossible to
really feed somebody else
if you yourself are starving.
And so, how are you feeding
your soul, your heart,
your mind right now?
Man, I've kind of have
clicked into war-time mode
as this has happened and, I'm
usually somewhat disciplined
and diligent about my morning routine.
I'm not missing it right now.
I'm up.
A good recommended book for yeah is called
"The Miracle Morning".
Changed my life years ago
when I was in a very hard
and kind of depressed season.
And I realized I have
to get up every morning
and work on myself first,
so I have something to give
throughout the day.
A lot of people need you right now
to be a source of
encouragement of stability.
But if you're unstable,
and you're not encouraged,
it's gonna be really hard
to show up for others.
So number four, be
thinking about self care.
If you wanna survive and thrive right now,
I think you have to be
thinking about not burning out
and just panicking over
the next couple weeks.
This thing, hopefully resolves soon,
or it might resolve in next year.
Like it might be a long
time that this is happening,
so we can't be frantic in terms of,
oh I better do something
in the next 10 days.
Yeah, we need to have some urgency.
But we also need to pace ourselves
so we don't burn out
and so we don't diminish
our immune system, especially in a time
when that matters more than ever before.
And then number five,
and after I give you guys some updates,
I've got some encouragement
at the end for you as well.
But number five is keep advancing.
Keep advancing, keep advancing.
Look, we could be going into
a real recession right now.
And the average person is receding.
Right, they're shrinking back.
We know the economy is receding
because jobs have been shut down
and businesses have been closed.
The truth is the world is
really receding right now.
There's been estimates
that the global, the GDP,
could be just that money is
evaporating out of the economy
'cause people aren't workin'.
And so we are going to
be seeing a recession.
But here's the truth.
You can't control that.
You can control what you do.
And my friend, you can advance.
What our option is is we can
actually choose in this season
to be bitter or we can
choose to get better.
And we also can choose how we
come out of this this season.
You know look, you might end up
with some debt because of this.
Maybe, you're here in America
and maybe you've lost your job
and you could get on unemployment,
but it might not be enough and so,
you might go back a
little bit financially.
That doesn't mean you have
to go back spiritually.
That doesn't mean that you have to
lose ground in your health.
It doesn't mean that
you have to lose ground
in your relationships.
There's things you can do
right now to set you up.
To actually take ground right now,
but also to set you up
to bounce out of this
with momentum, with energy,
with a new set of skills.
This is a time to advance.
The truth is, as an entrepreneur,
it's your responsibility to advance.
Look, the economy works
when people spend money,
when people offer products and services,
when people actually
add value to the system.
I think about one of
my favorite restaurants
here in Vegas, just closed their doors.
They're not offering to-go food.
They're not offering a chance to,
they didn't, maybe they weren't creative
and launched three new businesses,
but they just closed the doors completely.
They completely stopped.
Revenue, I bet the
employees had to be laid off
or at least frozen.
And Sonja and I, the other
day, we were frustrated
'cause we loved the food.
We wanted to go give them money
but they closed their doors.
Now's not the time to close and recede.
Now's the time to
reinvent yourself to pivot
and to be thinking about
how you can advance.
I know it's hard.
I know that it's discouraging.
I know that you might be wondering,
I don't know exactly what to do.
Well focus on what you can do
and you do know what to do.
I've learned that entrepreneurship
has a lot to do more than
with even tactics and strategies
that has a lot do with our mindset.
It has to do with just being
in the right state in our soul.
And so, what you can do is
is read books that are
gonna give you strategies
on leadership and
business and social media.
What you can do right
is invest in yourself.
What you can do is make sure you move
and get out a little bit.
Maybe you're literally locked inside,
but go for a walk.
Stay hydrated.
Get up, move a little bit.
Call your family.
If your family's positive.
I mean call in to check in on them,
but maybe call somebody
who's gonna spark your fire.
Listen to some music.
Dance a little bit.
Get dressed.
I'm kinda skipping ahead
into my daily routine tips
and how to stay motivated
when working from home.
But I tell you what, if
you're wearing pajamas
after four days as an
entrepreneur working from home,
that's the quickest path to depression.
Sometimes you gotta get up, get dressed,
even if you have nowhere to go
and act like a professional.
Because when you act like a professional,
then you're gonna show up in
the market as a professional
and you're gonna get professional results.
And so keep advancing
friends during this time.
There's so much out of our control.
I'm not saying everything's
gonna be perfect.
You know that.
You're already experiencing
a lot of setbacks.
But there's things out of your control
that we're just gonna have to deal with.
Far be it from us that we make it worse
by letting ourselves slip on
the things we can control.
Let's keep advancing.
If you're an entrepreneur right now
and you have a product or a service,
be bold about sharing it with people.
Some people might misunderstand it.
People question, should
I market right now?
Should I sell right now?
Yes!
Because when you, when someone invests
in your fitness training program,
and you get some money, and when then
you invest in some software.
And now you're buying some
video editing software
and some cameras.
Thank god, maybe we made some
affiliate money off that.
So we made some money.
And then you've invested
and Adobe made some money.
So their employees are still in business.
And when that camera
company made some money,
and then those employees can still
go to In and Out Burger so they can eat
and make some money and care their family
and those people can go
home and pay for Disney+,
as they watch The Mandalorian.
And Disney+ can keep paying their workers,
and then their workers can go home.
That is how the economy works, my friends.
And so as an entrepreneur,
as a content creator,
now is the time for you to
advance and not constrict.
Think about, you've got
products and services,
you're creating new value
in the market place.
Or you're just creating content
that people wanna consume
so they can take their minds off things,
and you can make money through brand deals
and affiliate marketing and YouTube ads.
We have to advance.
And look, we're in this together.
So now's our time to
punch fear in the face,
punch perfectionism in
the face and press record.
Leaders lead.
It's time for you to lead.
It's time for you to be a positive voice.
It's time for you to think
about how you can get up
every single day and be the role model
in your community, to your
family, for your kids,
for your future, for your
sister, for your brother,
for everybody around you.
And look as we do this together,
we're gonna get through this together.
So I appreciate you and
thanks so much for being here.
Well hey, thanks again for
being a part of this episode.
Just a couple reminders.
We are still on our way to
Grow with Video Live 2020,
here in Las Vegas in September.
Of course, if something major happens,
that's gonna be an online conference.
But the deal is, I've got
friends who've already
rescheduled their events for August,
in December, a couple of conferences
are coming here to Vegas
and this is an unpredictable time
but we are full speed ahead,
working with the hotel,
working with our full line up of speakers.
We got Vanessa Lao.
We got Heather Torres,
Chalene Johnson, Pete Vargas.
We've got Catherine from the Content Bug,
Roger Wakefield, Pat
Flynn, Benji Travis, man.
Go to GrowthVideoLive.com
and grab your ticket
because we've got the
best pricing right now.
And you may even wanna grab your travel.
I know flights like Southwest,
you can buy a ticket
and you can also cancel the ticket.
There's no loss on it.
Maybe you, you're fancier than Southwest.
I fly Southwest all the time.
But some other airlines
might have those extra fees.
But join us for Growth Video Live.
And if you haven't rated
and reviewed the podcast,
we're actually doing a
giveaway at the think,
if you go to ThinkMarketingShow.com,
you could be entered to win two tickets
to Grow with Video Live.
And no matter what,
we're gonna be delivering
and fulfilling on our promise to you
when you buy your ticket.
So get registered.
This is one of those investments
that you can make in your future right now
and we'll have a lot of
cool things coming up
for you regarding that.
Remember that next is what
is your next action step?
I hope that this podcast was inspiring.
I hope that you got a
few ideas, but success is
1% inspiration and 99% perspiration.
So what's our next action step?
Like what are you gonna
put into action from this?
And you probably don't need 50 ideas.
You may have 50.
But what are you gonna do next,
remember, calendar blocking.
Put it on your calendar.
Are you gonna shoot a video tomorrow,
schedule that live stream,
finally open up that
course you invested in
and grab that journal and
actually watch it and take notes?
And it's cool, I know, you've
been binging some shows,
just like me.
But maybe you don't need
to re-watch The Office
for the 10th time
through the whole season.
Maybe put that to the side,
grab your journal and learn something.
What is your next action step?
And then I gotta give a shout out
to our review of the week from xSkillzx.
It says, "Stop thinking, and start doing."
I love that.
Check out the review.
Super excited that these
two now have a podcast!
Though fairly new, the
value in this podcast
is just as incredible as their
YouTube channel, Think Media.
I'm grateful that I can now listen to them
on the same platform as the
rest of my favorite podcasters.
I have had the pleasure of meeting
Sean, Heather, and Melissa
in Sand Diego in last July
and they were truly amazing
people who want to help.
Subscribe to this and
all of their channels.
Thank you, xSkillzx for
the review of the week.
Think Marketing Podcast listeners,
please if you haven't
rated, reviewed, subscribed,
hit like and shared the podcast, do that.
Let's spread the word.
Come on, we need to spread good vibes
and good information during
this time more than ever before.
And remember, here at Think Media,
our company, our promise is to serve you,
purpose-driven people with
the best tips and tools
for building your influence
with online video.
We're on a mission to help 10,000 people
create a full-time living
doing what they love
with online video.
Are we saying that that's easy or instant?
Of course not.
Are we saying it's possible?
More than ever before.
More than ever before, live streaming,
video, YouTube, social media is exploding.
eMarketer did a huge article
about how social platforms
are increasing in value,
increasing in consumption.
Zoom is up 30% in their
value over the last month
'cause everyone's now
doing live streaming.
This is the time to be
investing in yourself
and your skills when it
comes to online video
and social media, and we are here to help.
So let's go out there this week,
and focus on our dreams, our goals
and get our most important
action items done.
I appreciate you, and I
will see you or hear you
or you'll hear me, or we'll connect
in the next episode of
the Think Marketing Show.
Talk soon.
(upbeat music)